today's video is sponsored by factor a
fantastic meal delivery service that's
all about providing convenient and
nutritious meals right to your doorstep
Factor offers delicious flavor-packed
options on the menu each week to fit a
variety of Lifestyles from keto to
calorie smart vegan plus veggie and
Protein Plus prepared by chefs and
approved by dietitians each factor meal
has all of the ingredients you need to
feel satisfied all day long while
meeting your goals Factor meals are
delivered fresh never Frozen to your
door just heat eat and enjoy a
nutritious and satisfying meal in just
minutes as someone with a busy schedule
who loves great flavors factor is a
game-changing solution Factor cuts down
on grocery trips and cooking so there's
more time for me to watch all of my
favorite and sinful TV shows my favorite
meals are the shredded chicken taco bowl
and the jalapeno beef mac and cheese on
a budget this month by cutting back on
takeout get Factor instead not only is
Factor cheaper than takeout but meals
are ready faster than restaurant
delivery as a special treat for our
viewers we've partnered with factor to
offer an exclusive discount you code TV
sins 50
off your first Factor box at
factor75.com so head on over to the link
in the description below explore factors
menu and start enjoying delicious Chef
crafted meals that will keep you on
track with your health goals thanks
again to factor for sponsoring today's
video
foreign
[Music]
did it not already we watched a boy lose
a testicle to a piranha in an eye bulge
monster Ripa High schooler's torso open
what is that if not dark maybe it was
one of your classmates Sheriff I find
that question offensive this was a
speculation or possibly an assertion but
not a question dead people are
notoriously bad at returning calls it's
2022 and so are the living what's your
point then I ran into Bianca Barclay and
I told her to go for help next thing I
remember I was awaking in my dorm we saw
you in your dorm at the end of the last
episode but the rest of this happened
completely off screen almost as if
police showing up the scene of Rowan's
murder hadn't been written yet I've
hibernated with Grizzlies I think these
references to ridiculous things that The
Adams Family have done are meant to
impress and shock but I've seen so much
odd that none of it is interesting
anymore however if she'd said that she
hibernated uncomfortable pillows in the
sunshine that would freak me out at this
point you have five minutes and
everything is off the Record saying off
the Record is more courtesy than law and
Sheriff Galpin is more law than
journalists so this statement was mostly
pointless Sheriff what you're gonna want
to see this better come take a look at
this cliche that was a fast reveal I'm
impressed I'm still annoyed but
impressed I like being an island not
naming the episode The Isle of Woe man
these kids are meticulously painting the
boat I mean they want it to be smooth
and solid fine be hyper perfectionist
but you do know this boat is being
designed to be attacked right maybe
paint is not as important to survival as
I don't know armor I've always hated the
expression right what you know it's a
hall pass for the imagination impaired
or maybe write what you know means that
you should learn about a topic before
you decide to write about it but that
might just be me using my imagination
the only reason we're interested in this
symbol is that the music is creepy and
we've had a Thrust in our face without
that context this stamp might as well be
the remnants of a daisy smashed against
a page as a bookmark I need to speak
with
find him it won't be possible I'm afraid
it's been expelled this sounds like he'd
already left school but then she says
he'll be on the first train out this
afternoon and it now sounds like he's
been put in solitary confinement while
this is believable and Nevermore why
doesn't she just go with the he has
already left school explanation instead
of the elaborate train station plan that
ultimately causes Wednesday to become
more suspicious not until you've picked
your extracurricular activity show
suddenly remembers it's about a boarding
school and has to act like picking a
club is as important as all the mystery
and murder I mean at least she doesn't
pick mathletes it's social suicide
squares
on scales the fish people singing about
scales is a bit on the gills also if we
wanted to be gleeful we wouldn't be
watching Wednesday
[Music]
not only dogs can hear and yet none of
the werewolves will react to this hey
you know girls in glass houses to throw
bigger Stones turning the saying on its
head but not aiming for the ceiling at
least I'm not an elitist snob says the
person's snobbly stealing the convenient
hey apple and piercing it perfectly in
the bullseye like an elite [__] this
type of train just does not exist in
Vermont a little bit of research
suggests this exterior is actually
Romania and no amount of American flags
will make me see anything else now
stupid train no one sees a liberated
hand clickety-clacking through a busy
train terminal no one no one weens
leaves this bag unattended and Saunders
off not even a little worried about the
bomb scare she's probably responsible
for damn the talent it must take to be
this digitally expressive Victor
dorobonsu sure has his finger on the
pulse of this character and the job he
does with his hand is gonna massage a
sin removal out of me isn't it setting
up this whole shape-shifting trip to
cover up Rowan's disappearance just to
compromise the whole thing by changing
back into yourself before you've even
left the train station a lefty wouldn't
have failed me being a dick to your
thing dendrophylex and denii otherwise
known as the ghost orchid first
discovered on the Isle of Wight in 1854.
well actually dendrophyllax lindenii was
discovered in Cuba in 1844 however a
different ghost orchid named
epipogiomophilum was discovered amongst
the meat pies in 1854. but as it turns
out neither is carnivorous looks like
you may have competition for first chair
Bianca there's a first chair and botany
what are they playing the trumpet flower
it's able to thrive and even the most
hostile environments but its mere
presence can change the ecosystem
causing the established plants to reject
it are we supposed to invest in these
mean girls going wild for botany and not
think this all seems a bit trivial next
to the murder that happened in the last
episode we're talking about Mom I'd say
skip but the dad walks away from his son
and ignores this emotional moment
completely so the sin here is obviously
not making your kid power wash whatever
is currently growing on the siding of
your house
driving off like this with Elvis in the
bed of your truck I know I'm stubborn
single-minded and obsessive
but those are all traits of great
writers
yes and serial killers
what's your point being stubborn
single-minded and obsessive are the
traits of many people not just writers
and serial killers Panda fluffers fit
that description just you know off the
top of my head when Bowen showed me this
it confirmed my greatest fear that I'm
going to be responsible for something
terrible
not good terrible like Ivan bad terrible
when you're good terrible involves
things like torture and executions we're
gonna need a bit more info to understand
what bad terrible means it can be
anything from a war crime to wearing a
hat that doesn't suit you it's
manager a Dumb and Dumber story
every big smoker and I handle it like a
pro
would you like to see it Eugene's
probably being literal but the writers
are being perverts
[Music]
up with this bullsh we've watched
Wednesday obliterate every obstacle in
her path with weaponry sassory and
hand-to-hand combatery you know that the
moment a stranger grabs her body she
would rip them limb from limb these are
Romans
I knew it was a cover-up
expo's original flashbacks
on two vampires
okay fine she said fanging but this is
really just a combination of banging and
[__] in the correct combination of
the two is obviously baking color me
intrigued I thought you were allergic to
color the most interesting plants grow
in the shade hibiscus has entered the
chat and heard you were talking I mean
who's gonna tell this guy that he
doesn't have to pick up leaves with the
trash poker he was doing it earlier too
take a break man and while you're
thinking about how you wound up here ask
yourself if Lawn Care via trash poker is
really what you want to do until
retirement it's not too late to change
to spear fishing
earlier in the episode Xavier bought to
life the spider he was catching in his
notebook and now I'm just wondering what
he makes this picture do when no one's
looking having a UV light ready to go
pointing it anywhere in this room and
turning it on without even a little
hesitation how'd you get past the house
Master use your siren Powers not while
wearing this the introduction of this
necklace couldn't have been more
heavy-handed if Bianca looked right at
the camera and said hey look at this
thing trust me Wednesday Adams is not
the girl of your dreams
she's the stuff of your nightmares is
that not a compliment at this school
it's really hard to tell when they like
fun when they like scary when the two of
them are the same thing also is using
her surname necessary is there a
different Wednesday that might be the
girl of his dreams Yoko is in the
infirmary what happened garlic bread
incident at dinner this just sounds like
a jam band happened so
poke up and I don't have a co-pilot
correction you don't have a Yoko pilot
there are no rules in the pokeup and she
is a siren which makes her master of the
water then we just need a beater at our
own game you don't need to be Master of
the water to declare yourself the
unequivocal winner without setting foot
in the canoe and that's well within the
established non-existent rules of this
race now in case you haven't caught on
I'm saying that it's impossible to have
any kind of race without there being at
least a minimal set of rules you wanna
tell me what you two were up to all
night and spoil the surprise Wednesday's
secrecy is all about keeping the
audience in suspense there's not a
single reason you should be surprising
your team in the middle of the boat race
OMG you look perfect
she does it's amazing how good anyone
can look in a cat suit that mysteriously
fits their exact measurements
[Music]
even if principal Weems needs a real gun
for this did it need to be Dirty Harry's
44 magnum the attempted murder of the
black cats crew is so telegraphed that
it not only fails on the first swipe but
on the second as well
[Music]
wow sure was convenient that the net was
installed to launch in the exact same
direction as the mer Saboteur I guess
Wednesday has premonitions about all
sorts of things that make the plot sail
along episode suddenly becomes that
scene from Lord of the things when Bilbo
Adams is transported to the upside down
for some reason
and you are the vague idea of what the
[__] is going on right now what's going
on it is very obvious that your canoe is
sinking why is the reaction dialogue so
bad in the scene also for some reason
these holes cause them to forget how to
paddle and they all settle on just
stirring the water I just asked myself
wwwd what would Wednesday do she
wouldn't use an initialism that requires
her to then waste more time explaining
what the initialism meant if these
spikes are high enough above the water
line so that Wednesday's boat doesn't
sink when they're deployed wouldn't the
holes they make in the other boat also
be above the water line what are you
doing down here oh I'm just conveniently
accidentling my way into Clues crucial
to the plot the last time Ophelia Hall
won the pro cup
or mother Captain the team if they're
gonna dive this deep into Legacy
nonsense they might as well have
Wednesday reveal that she's a Skywalker
too Nevermore continues to be an enigma
a place where the questions far away the
answers writers admit to using the Lost
strategy of stretching out your
storyline but sometimes the answer is
staring you right in the face or in this
case a clue that leads to more clues
that lead to a library where you won't
find answers this episode
[Music]
shut up with this bullary we've been
through this already should rip this
person limb from limb Lim from lamb
foreign
out a few yards and start drowning I
don't do tears
don't be an [__]
the chance that Enid ever becomes
romantically interested in you is less
than one percent that's math and
have you seen this before
you know for kids to tell you the truth
I've never really fitting anywhere too
odd for the normies not odd enough for
the outcasts a high-powered mutant of
some kind never even considered for mass
production
oh
Brutus is just as cute as Caesar okay
Brutus is just as smart as Caesar people
totally like Brutus just as much as they
like Caesar and when did it become okay
for one person to be the boss of
everybody huh because that's not what
Rome is about we should totally just
stab speaker